we were talking about it with like
school shootings what leads some of
these people to get so caught up and I
think for one if you don't have any
purpose through like a job through a
family have like love in your life like
something that gives you purpose every
day and you're really at the whims of
social media or anything tailored
towards if you start looking at
something bad it just gives you more bad
you know it's almost like a Pandora's
Box in a way yeah the school shooting
thing is interesting because
what's going on there is that there is
now a kind of uh it's funny I'm doing in
this season uh my podcast I'm doing a
whole thing about gun violence so I've
been thinking a lot about this and we
have an episode where we talk a lot
about about mass shootings
and I think the psychology
of that is really
going back to the idea of those three
layers of
that there's a world now a kind of
closed culture online of people who are
unhealthily obsessed pathologically
obsessed with this kind of violence and
there there is no they've they've been
cut off from the third layer they're not
checking their ideas against what the
broader world looks like they're totally
enclosed in this sealed
online culture where the only feedback
they're getting are from people who
think exactly like they do and who feed
their kind of obsessive Fascination and
addiction for this kind of weird
violence like if you look at people who
have been involved in mass shootings
um they're immersed in that world they
know they can talk obsessively for hours
about like the kids who did the
Columbine shoots oh yeah there's bootleg
manifestos there's people getting like
yeah have you heard this manifest have
you read this it's his own little world
hermetically seen world and like there's
no connection to the kind of broader
society and so they've become to think
of they come to think they get they're
getting all their validation from that
first layer
right that's what sort of that and so
you know breaking
trying to solve this puzzle of mass
shootings requires at some point to
getting access to those kids and kind of
breaking them out of that
um uh closed Universe yeah and the the
interesting about like all but with
online and living in online societies
now it's like you can find whatever
Universe whatever Universe you start to
create right whether it's good or bad
that there's this other energy from the
other side it's almost like the mirror
we're used to look in a mirror and you
would get like an Earnest reflection
yourself it would be based on sometimes
you might not see yourself clearly
because of how you thought about
yourself or how you felt about yourself
but at least the mirror was going to
give you
it was an honest reflection there was no
ability to change the mirror unless you
were in a fun house or something the
mirror was the mirror but now the mirror
has the ability
to kind of adjust the way you look at
yourself or to give you Reflections that
make you think the same things over and
over again yeah like with um algorithms
and that sort of thing with social media
you know because now we're not even the
mirror is just our phone we're looking
in there for so much validation yeah um
it's really weird when the mirror now
has the pat it's like that's freaking
really scary because if you get somebody
in a dark hole who doesn't have a strong
connection to our purpose in the world
where they feel some one of the senses
of value from themselves from other
people what are the other two
from the internal your immediate world
of people who share your community and
then the broader world and then yeah
yeah if you're not feeling some of that
and you're just in your intern just in
this kind of a closed space or even in a
a space that the mirror starts to design
that's really if you get into the dark
arts a little bit and it's only showing
you Dark Art and everybody in there is a
dark artist and you're like damn this is
the world yeah that's real scary man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one